are often copied and imitated but never
equaled spin balls from fun and motion
toys have a new revision and it's
actually pretty great Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain today I've got a
review of the glow zero spin balls from
Fun In Motion toys and if you've got a
little flow artist in your life you're
going to want to tune in for this one
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission for those of
you not in the know spin balls and their
parent company fun and motion toys have
been around for about a decade they've
been producing low-cost entry-level LED
POI targeted towards Boutique toy stores
around the country since their Inception
they're kind of the perfect POI for kids
to begin to learn how to get into POI
spinning and flow Arts they're light
soft and super intuitive and easy to use
and in their latest revision spin balls
have added or improved upon pre-existing
features to make their POI longer
lasting and more versatile I'll take you
through my usual review rubric outlining
features ease of use brightness
durability battery life as well as
sharing some of my own personal thoughts
about how they feel to spin before we
talk about price
so first up let's look at features
spinball's heads are soft silicone that
can take a hit with minimal impact they
have internal batteries that recharge
via micro USB and a single button
interface for turning the POI on and off
as well as shifting through their modes
these rechargeable batteries are a major
upgrade as for years they'd run off of
watch batteries that would require using
a small screwdriver to get access to the
battery compartment this wasn't ideal
both because they ran off of hard to
find watch batteries and it was real
easy to lose that screwdriver having the
rechargeable option is fantastic both
because it saves waste from the
batteries and also it presents less of a
barrier to continued use for months and
even years the upgrade was a fantastic
choice and fixed one of my major pain
points with the previous version of this
product as for the LEDs themselves that
button allows you to access up to 22
different modes including a variety of
Fades strobes and individual colors they
also have the option of creating a
custom mode out of any three colors you
choose the number of modes is also new
as is the custom programming feature
this this brings these sets of poi more
imperative with sets that are targeted
in adults on the market by giving them
access to more modes and letting them
customize at least one the tethers are
nylon cord that doubles back upon itself
to quickly trade out a variety of
different custom lengths you can
disconnect each other's from the heads
reset the length by sliding the knot up
and down the tether and then
reconnecting the tether to the head and
I won't lie these have been my other big
pain point with spin balls for a long
time what tends to happen is that
because the nylon cords are kind of
stretchy the knot will start to crawl
its way up the side of the tether that
directly connects to the head and the
handle it winds up looking pretty messy
and can require further readjustments as
well as turning Tangles into absolute
masses of spaghetti now the manual says
there's instructions for dealing with
the excess tether on the website but I
was unable to find this information in
time for this review
it's hardly a deal breaker and I think
most kids are unlikely to care but it is
a spot where I think they could still
use some Polish as for the handles
themselves these are definitely an old
school Blast from the Past they come
with finger loops and swivels So in
theory you can bust out some orbitals
now I myself I haven't really used
finger Loops in the better part of a
decade but they are super helpful for
little kids that might be learning to
hold POI for the first time rather than
trusting that they can keep a grip on
the handles as they swing them around
you can be sure that the POI will not
suddenly become uncontrolled projectiles
nice for peace of mind
cool now let's dive into ease of use
so as sets of LED POI go these really
could not be easier you just push the
button to turn them on and navigate
through the modes and then hold it down
to turn the POI back off my usual test
in this category is whether I could
figure out how to turn on the POI and
find a mode that I like without
consulting the manual I'm pleased to say
that spin balls gets an A plus on this
point passing with flying colors
pun intended I think kids playing with
them might need a little bit of
instruction to get the hang of putting
on and taking off the finger loops and
of course there's the stuff with the
tether that I mentioned in the last
section but overall you can tell these
have been designed end to end to make
them as accessible as possible the
custom mode I would not likely have been
able to figure out on my own but being
as how every company pretty much has its
own unique system for programming custom
modes I don't think that should be
surprising either so yeah I don't know
that I've ever encountered another set
of poi that were this easy and intuitive
to use well done there
next up let's talk brightness
okay so this was another major area of
improvement in this latest revision on
older generations of spin balls the
light was so dim it would typically be
pretty dark out before I could really
clearly make out that the balls were
glowing much less what color they were
granted they aren't as bright as many of
the LED POI on the market currently that
shoot for really intense brightness but
they are so noticeably brighter than
past versions that it made me realize
for the first time just how much of an
impact brightness has on my desire to
pick a set of LED props up these new
spin balls felt much more inviting and
professional and I was not expecting
that here's to an upgrade that I did not
know that I needed
next up let's talk durability
so I have used many many sets of spin
balls in my day and I have never broken
a set that isn't to say that they're
indestructible just that they've put up
with all the punishment that I've given
them I've seen kids use and abuse them
with varying degrees of intensity and
I've yet to see a catastrophic failure
if you're worried whether what'll break
first is the POI or your child's
attention span the answer is most
definitely the latter
now let's get into battery life
so as is the case with many other sets
of LED POI have come in contact with in
the past few years this is where we get
a trade-off for that brightness I have
two tests that I run on every set of LED
POI that I review I turn them on as
bright as they'll go in solid white mode
and let the battery run out because it's
the most punishing test that I can give
them next I'll turn on a rainbow fade
mode because in theory it should more
closely match the most common use cases
for Led POI and give people a better
idea of the performance that they can
expect for their own use my solid white
test got between two and a half to three
hours of battery life before conking out
my rainbow fade mode got essentially the
same performance it's interesting that
the two wound up being functionally
interchangeable but either way the
takeaway here is that you've probably
got around three hours of use before you
need to recharge them also just kind of
an odd note to put in here because I
can't think of where else to put it when
I perform my rainbow fade tests I know
something kind of odd I turn the two
point on at exactly the same time and I
would think that that would mean that
they'd stay in sync as they faded
between colors but by 40 minutes in
they'd begun to get noticeably out of
sync not sure why and I don't think it
has any real impact on use but I did
find it a little odd cool so now let's
talk about personal thoughts and how
they feel so if I can be real with y'all
I was really surprised by how much I
enjoyed playing with these usually
spinning spin balls feel so radically
different from my other sets of poi that
if I know I'm going to be using spin
balls for a specific task I'll actually
avoid using any other sets of poi for at
least a day or so ahead of time to
acclimate now I don't know if the heads
are heavier now or I just got used to
spinning lighter POI or what but these
actually felt really comfortable and
I've been switching back and forth
between them and other sets of poi
pretty easily I rarely use finger Loops
but they provide enough surface area
that I can hold onto them like I would a
small ball handle it works well enough
for my purposes and while I was getting
prepped for this review it also dawned
on me that kids might not actually be
the sole or even best use case for these
as a Target audience there's plenty of
people who can benefit from lighter sets
of poi that don't require a lot of grip
strength to use including elderly people
people with certain types of physical
disabilities and people prone to
shoulder problems so if you find contact
POI to be a little too Hefty or unwieldy
for whatever reason these might not be a
bad option to explore overall the
upgrades have all been overwhelmingly
positive these feel more like a solid
set of poi and less like a toy that's
going to wind up in the bottom of a
drawer I dig the changes well done to
the team at fun and motion toys spin
balls glow zero LED POI are available
for 24.99 and no that is not a typo over
at funimotiontoys.com they come with a
manual and micro USB charging cables you
can also download an app to learn the
basics of poi with them and it features
a stunningly handsome instructor to
guide you through a comprehensive set of
lessons also I've got a deal with funny
motion toys so if you'd like to get a
discount on a set of spin balls or any
other of the flow Arts inspired toys
they make you can use my code drexfactor
at checkout it also helps out the
channel so thank you in advance
[Music]
did you get anything out of this review
what are your experiences with spin
balls did you get duped into buying one
of the knockoffs let me know down in the
comments also be sure to subscribe to
get more tutorials reviews and flow
sessions from me this video would not be
possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
one and all for your support do you like
my videos do you like my flow sessions
logs reviews Combos and more I'm on a
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to The Wider world and help people
connect with their brains and their
bodies so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and help me along in
my mission do check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
more of my reviews for Led POI I will
leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching this
video on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you'll like this
top video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look too
thanks so much for watching and make
sure to get outside to flow today we'll
see you with a new video on Wednesday
peace